[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are the boys of BTS the new Beatles you
may have heard this new musical craze
sweeping the globe these fellows are
really something they called BTS and
people are so excited you can you can
only call it fetus mania that Stephen
Colbert in black and white playing off
the comparisons fans have been making
between the kpop band and the Fab Four
during the cold open of The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert Wednesday night now
these boys aren't from America no
they're from across the pond the big one
the one with Hawaii in the middle there
really are fine group of youngsters in
fact you can call them the Fab seven
it's got a nice ring to it
Colbert had the band members introduce
themselves and I'm telling you guys they
are giving off some major John Paul
George and Ringo vibes are you doing
tomorrow I'm a nice boy sugar hi my name
is P and I'm a good boy I'm your hope
you're my hope I'm Jay home hi I'm
Simeon nice to meet you guys hello I'm
worldwide the handsome gin you know I'm
gonna go thank you for inviting us not
seeing the similarities well just wait
because BTS and the Late Show worked
together to transform the Ed Sullivan
Theater where the show tapes to look
similar to how it did in February 1964
when the Beatles made their us TV debut
on The Ed Sullivan Show
[Applause]
now check out BTS performing boy with
love
[Music]
guys I'm shook I also need a little more
so roll the tape
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
totally betta Lee right while the
comparisons are rooted in more than just
their insane international fandom and
the fact that they are a boyband
BTS recently became the first band since
the Beatles to earn three billboard
number-one albums in a single year with
their latest map of the soul persona and
they admitted the comparisons are super
flattering during their stop by Good
Morning America we're all fanboys abidos
of course I mean who is not and you know
we are just feel so honored to be with
the greatest names in music the guys put
the Beatle spooped to the side for a hot
second though and sat down for a chat
with Colbert where do you guys see
yourselves in 10 years maybe maybe 36 36
less that's stache big handlebar big
handlebar moustache well session long
hair it's a boy yeah they also gushed
over their mega fan base and I mean mega
the army they are the most passionate
people
where's Connor thank you and I love you
you're my everything and it's always
been all about their fans just check out
what they told et back in 2017 no are
you looking we got our armies we got
like thousands of girlfriends today and
here at Mike Ross selfie arena so we
don't worry no need to worry
tell me about arriving in America at LAX
and the fans when you stepped off the
plane so we never expected like so much
fans in the airport tell I really like
there were some photos of us and he's
like fakes like what do you think about
kids not going to school so they can see
you playing
what watch TV police I'm sorry but we're
living in 2017 you can watch it YouTube
maybe later haha okay so I'm not gonna
lie to you guys I didn't really get BTS
at first but now I'm fully onboard and
I'm just trying to pick out who my
favorite is and I love love love how
sweet and appreciative they are of their
fans I think it's pretty cute of course
we'll be here to keep you up to date on
all things BTS so be sure to keep it
locked on et until next time I'm Holly
Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]